let's go to some interesting posts I
noticed on the David Pakman show
subreddit of course the david pakman
show subreddit now approaching 16,000 of
our viewers and listeners who are
subscribed at david pakman.com slash
reddit the first one from a user named
twelve tribes called simply speak
English writing Republicans will tell
you this is America and in America we
speak English well it's time to we tell
Republicans to speak English and we need
to do so ourselves we need to speak
English not Latin
in English we call it bribery not a quid
pro quo speak English and some people
pointing out it may not just be bribery
what happened with Ukraine we could be
talking about extortion we could be
talking about witness tampering
increasingly as we have threats to
whistleblowers and the Outing of
whistleblowers or alleged whistleblowers
by Don jr. which we will talk about
later on in the program also by the way
when I saw this is saying we should tell
Republicans to speak English I thought
it was a reference to Donald Trump's
very poor command of the English
language but it wasn't it was about
something else here's a funny post
conservative contributions to society
this is so good I'm wondering what you
all can brainstorm as conservative
right-wing or Republican contributions
to America in the last hundred years I'm
thinking positive contributions like the
left in America has brought us an
endless amount of from the New Deal
welfare state women's rights civil
rights workers rights consumer
protection environmental protection the
one point I keep coming back to as a
possible positive contribution is that
conservatives pushed to expand the
consumer economy as well as the size and
scope of the presence of our military
around the world of course this has
brought back a world of negative
consequences on us and that same
expansive consumer economy with
regulations rolled back to achieve it
has exploded inequality and strained the
fabric of our society to a near breaking
point and huge parts of the rest of the
world despise us to the point of picking
up arms against us on official and
unofficial battlefields help me out here
what have conservatives done for us so
you're getting to something very
important here and this is what you have
to understand
to them blocking anything from happening
is a contribution because conservatism
by definition wants to conserve what is
already there blocking the government
from doing things is considered a
contribution to society for them because
they don't want government doing things
unless of course you need gay marriage
is blocked or you need rules about who's
allowed to go in bathrooms then all of a
sudden the government needs to
immediately act to stop immorality or
whatever it is that they say but that's
why we are at a disadvantage they win
merely by gumming up the process of
democracy and preventing government from
doing things preventing the left and
Democrats or whoever from doing things
that is their ideology so we are at a
fundamental disadvantage and you are
correctly pointing out that when you
talk about the accomplishments there are
cut what they see as an accomplishment
is just preventing anything from
changing preventing government from
doing things period join the discussion
at david pakman.com slash read it very
exciting stuff happening there every day